ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนกลับมาเจอกันกับมาเจอ
พี่เอ็ดดี้กลับมาเจอน้องเรียมในช่อง
คอมพลีเมนเซิร์ฟเวอร์ไทยเย้
เย 5 วันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันนี้วันที่วัน
ที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้วันนี้วันที่ 5 วัน
นี้วันนี้วันที่ 5 วันที่ 5 วันที่ 5 วัน
อะไรครับ
วันพุธอ้าวันพุธที่ 5 นะครับอ่าวันพุธที่
5 แล้วเดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้เดือนมกราคม
เดือน
มกราคมนะครับอ่าแล้วปีโห้ปี 10 คศอะไร
ครับ
พ.ต.
2022 ครับแล้วปี
ก็ขอ
พ.ศ.อะไรครับ
2,000 บาทก็ร้อย 65
แย่
2565 นะครับอ่าปีนี้นะครับโอเคแล้วแล้ว
วันนี้วันนี้วันที่ 5 เมื่อวานครับเมื่อ
วานวันที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
เมื่อวานวันที่ 4 เมื่อวานวันที่ 4 นะ
ครับอ่าแล้วพรุ่งนี้ล่ะครับพรุ่งนี้วัน
อะไรครับ
พรุ่งนี้วันที่ 6 พรุ่งนี้วันที่ 6 ใจเขา
พรุ่งนี้วันที่ 6
พฤหัสบดีอ่าพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสใช่ไหมครับ
เพราะว่าวันนี้วันพุธพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
โอเคพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีแล้วเมื่อวานและ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรครับ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคาร
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคารเดี๋ยว k  k  OK อ้า
อันนี้มะรืนนิเมื่อรืนนี้วันอะไรเข้ามา
รืนนี้วันศุกร์อาใช่ครับมะรืนนี้นี่มะรืน
นี้วันศุกร์โอเควันมะรืนนี้วันศุกร์แล้ว
มะรืนนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
มะรืนนี้วันที่เจ็ดอ้ามะรืนนี้วันที่ 7
ใส่ครับเย้
ๆทำปริญนี้วันที่เจ็ดสิบห้าวันนี้ตอนนี้
กี่โมงแล้วครับ
ตอนนี้
17:15 โมง
อีก 15 นาทีอ่ะเป็นตอนเช้าหรือตอนเย็น
ครับตอนเย็นค่ะตอนเย็นโอเค 5 โมง 15 นาที
หน้าวันนี้เราจะมาพูดอ่า
เรื่องอะไรถึงกันดีครับวันนี้
วันนี้เราจะมาพูดเรื่อง
อารมณ์ใช่ครับอ่ะเอ้ารมนะครับวันนี้เพลีย
ตีมีเรื่องของอารมณ์จะมาคุยกันเรื่องของ
อารมณ์มีอารมณ์อะไรบ้างที่น้องเรียมรู้
จักครับ
มีอารมณ์อารมณ์แรกนี้อารมณ์นี้รมนี้
ว้าว
ดีใจอารมณ์ดีใจนะครับอ่ะเออเออ
ตอนไหนบ้างที่เราดีใจครับ
แล้วดีใจตอนไหนมาตอนไหนที่เราดีใจว่าง
ครับเตรียมกินอาหารอร่อยอ๋อกินอาหารอร่อย
ครับดีใจใช่ไหมดีใจที่ได้กินอาหาร
โอเคบางทีบางทีเราดีใจตอนที่เราเราได้รับ
ของขวัญได้รับของขวัญดีใจไหมดีใจใจใช้
ครับโหได้ของขวัญดีดีดีใจใช่ไหมค่ะดีใจดี
ใจนะครับเวลาดีใจเราทำเราเป็นไงครับเรา
ยิ้มใช่ไหมเรายิ้มหน้ายิ้มได้ไหมครับเวลา
ยิ้มบางคนยิ้มยิ้มดีใจมากมีใจมากยิ้มหลับ
ตาหลับๆใจกับอ่านี่ยิ้มหลับตายิ้มรับซา
ด้วยครับอ้ายิ้มตัดเพชรดีดีใจมากขึ้นฮิฮิ
ตักมาชิมอันนี้อ้าปากกว้างเลยอ้าปากบาง
ยิ้มวอลว่างไม่ครับ R ยิ้มขว้างเลยดีใจๆ
ดีใจให้ค่ะเครียดอิอิได้ของลอตเตอรี่
หราคะโอ้ยดีใจดีใจมากตาตาโตตาโตเลยโอ๊ยดี
ใจฟูแบตเตอรี่
หาๆใช่ครับถูกลอตเตอรี่มีเงินมากมีเงิน
มากเลยมีเงินมาก
ห้าใช่ครับมีเงินมากอาอิตาลีได้ครับดีไทย
น้องเรียมซื้อซื้อลอตเตอรี่ไหมซื้อแมท
เตรียมเมื่อก่อนคไปซื้อลอตเตอรี่ครับตอน
นี้ไม่ซื้อไม่ซื้อก็ไม่ถูก
เฮ้ยเมื่อก่อนซื้อ
ไม่ถูกขอไม่ถูกก็ไม่ดีใจด้วยนะไม่ดีใจเธอ
ก็เลยไม่ซื้อ
ไม่ซื้อเบียร์ตีเกาะใบซื้อ
ของเล่นขั้น
เมื่อกี้ไม่ซื้อก็ไม่ถูกนะคะถูกใช่เราก็
ว่าไม่ได้ซื้อโอเคอารมณ์นี้เรียกว่าดีใจ
ใช่ไหมดีใจอ่ะถูกลอตเตอรี่่มีความสุขเวลา
ที่เรามีความสุขเราก็ดีใจเฮ้ยดีใจมีความ
สุขนะโอเคแล้วก็อ้าถ้าเราอ่า
อันนี้อันนี้อันนี้ก็มีความสุขเหมือนกัน
อุ้ยดีใจเหมือนกันแต่เขากำลังอะไรครับหัว
ร้อนหัวร้อนใช่ครับน่าหัวเราะหัวเราะฮ่าๆ
ๆๆตอนไหนบ้างที่เราจะหัวเราะครับ
หัวอ่านนักเรียนหัวเราะตอนไหนบ้าง
ดูดู
ตลกในคือ The  Photo หลอกดูตลกในทีวีหรือ
ตลกในทีวีแล้วหัวเราะใช่ไหมครับน้า
หัวเราะ
หาๆโอเคอ้าหัวเราะเวลาที่เราทำอะไรสนุกๆ
นะคุยคุยพี่คุยกับเพื่อนคุยสนุกหน่อยก็
หัวเราะ
หัวเราะได้ใช่ครับน่าดูทีวีดูอ่ะดูตลกใช่
ไหมเมื่อกี้น้องเอ็มดูตลกๆก็คือการที่คน
ทั่วโลกอ่าตลกก็อยู่ในทีวีมี YouTube ก็
มีใน YouTube ก็มีตลกในติ๊กต๊อกให้ติ๊ก
ตอกก็มีตลกเยอะนะเวลาดูติ๊กต๊อกก็จะตลก
หัวเราะ
งานครับ
แล้วพี่อาร์ตี้หัวเราะกับอย่างอื่นอีกไหม
คะอ่ะอ่ามี
ตลอกมีหนังนะครับแล้วก็มีหัวเราะบางทีพี่
ก็หัวเราะกับอ่าสัตว์เลี้ยงหน้าพี่ตี้
เลี้ยงหมาผีตี้มีหมาอยู่บางที่หมาก็ทำทำ
ท่าตลกๆใจครับหน้าบางทีหมาก็มาสะกิดสะกิด
ขอขนม 5 ขอขนมทำท่าตลกๆมิติก็หัวเราะ
ทราย
หืออ้าโอเคมีอารมณ์ดีใจใช่ไหมครับดีใจเรา
ก็ยิ้มเราก็หัวอีกต่อไปครับต่อไปเป็นอ่า
อารมณ์ดีใจและดีใจแล้วต่อไปก็เป็นอันนี้
ครับนี้เป็นไงครับ
เตาซาวหายเศร้าเศร้าฮะอ่ากำลังคะนี้เขา
กำลังทำอะไรครับเนี่ย
ร้องไห้อ้าร้องไห้น่าเศร้าร้องไห้เวลา
ร้องให้มีน้ำตานี่น้ำตานะครับอ่ามีน้ำตา
ร้องไห้ร้องไห้ทำไมเราถึงร้องไห้ครับบาง
ร้องไห้จากอะไรบ้างครับ
เราเสียใจเราเสียใจ
Series ขอดูซีรีย์โรงเรียนดูซีรีย์ก็
เสียใจใช่ไหมเสียใจร้องไห้อ๋ออ๋อร้องให้
มีน้ำตาอันนี้เป็นอารมณ์อารมณ์เศร้าหน้า
หรืออารมณ์เสียถ้าใครได้ครับ
ใช่ค่ะเรียบร้องไห้ร้องไห้ตาบวมอ๋อ
แสดงว่าเศร้ามากเสียใจมากใช่ๆครับ
เสียใจมากร้องไห้
เสียใจที่ไม่ถูกและรี่เสียใจ
ให้ตาต่างเดียม
ตาเค้าทาบวมเหรอเวลาร้องไห้ร้องไห้ป่าก็
จะเหลือแค่นี้
ขอ
ให้อะไรก็มีน้ำตา
น้ำตาน้ำตา
น้ำตาออกมา
ใช่ค่ะอันนี้เรียกว่าอ่ะน้องบัวม.คตาบวม
ร้องไห้ได้ครับงานบางครั้งบางครั้งเราก็
ร้องไห้ตอนที่เราจะเจ็บเจ็บหน้าสมมติอ่า
ตอนเด็กๆพี่อาร์ตี้ปั่นจักรยานปั่น
จักรยานล้มล้มเฮ็ดดีก็เจ็บโอ้ยเจ็บขาร้อง
ไห้ร้องไห้แต่ครับหน้ายังภาพนี้ครับถ้ามี
นี่เด็กผู้ชายคนนี้ก็ร้องไห้ใช่ไหมครับ
ร้องไห้เจ็บร้องไห้พระเจ็บหาไปหาคุณแม่
คุณแม่กอดก่อนอ่ะร้องไห้
ร้องไห้เสียใจเศร้าใจปั่นจักรยานล้มใน
ครับ
ร้องไห้หานักเรียนเคยเคยร้องไห้เคยร้องดี
ๆไหมครับ
เตรียมร้องไห้บ่อยมากๆ
ทำไมทำไมร้องไห้บ่คอย
เตรียมดูดูทีวี
อ่อนดูทีวีบ่อยโอเคเจอ
แล้วก็
ร้องไม่ฮ่าๆ
ถ้างั้นพี่คิดว่าคิดว่าน้องเรียนต้องดู
ตลกเยอะๆจะได้หัวเราะ
ไม่ร้อนให้
แล้วตอนเตรียมเด็กๆเขามีจักรยาน
มีจากการเหมือนกัน
ใต้เด็กๆมีจักรยานเด็กๆมีแต่กระยาน
ชายมีจักรยานแล้วเรียนก็ไม่ชอบใส่รองเท้า
ใหม่
อ่าใส่รองเท้า
รองเท้าเนี่ยอยู่ไหนน้าหานี่เช้า
เช้าเตรียมไม่ใส่ไม่ใส่รองเท้า
ครับ
ผมก็เป็นปั่นก็ปั่นจักรยานไม่ใส่รองเท้า
ได้ปั่นจักรยานไม่ใส่รองเท้ากอดอ้าย
ได้แต่วันนิ้วนิ้วตรงนี้อาหารติดขอไปตีบ
อยู่อ๋อ
KR ต้องตรงที่ปั่นจักรยานที่ปั่นจักรยาน
มันจะเป็นแบบนี้นะเบียร์ที่วาดที่ปั่น
จักรยานจะเป็นแบบนี้เป็นอย่างนี้
น่าจะใช่ไหมเขาเรียกบันไดอ้าบันไดคนไทย
เรียกบันได
บันไดปั่นจักรยานอ่ะเป็นแบบนี้ให้
จะมีช่องว่างอยู่ตรงนี้
ใช่ห่าแล้วนิ้วนิ้วน้องเรียมก็เข้าไปติด
ใช่ติดอยู่
อามินิ้วอามินิ้ว
นิ้วนิ้วนี้ก็ไปติดอยู่ในช่องนี้
ใช่อ๋อติดอยู่เอาไม่ออกติดติดนี่อ้อพี่
ออกนี่เค้าจักรยานล้มเราก็เรียงกันดอนนอน
อยู่
นี่ติดนอนร้องไห้อยู่สมัยนอนร้องไห้
หมดร้องไห้
อ๋อโอเคอ่า
ก็ร้องไห้
ร้องคนทุกๆคนก็หัวเราะฮ่าๆ
เรียงเบียร์ร้องไห้
อริเกเตอร์ณโรงเรียนเศร้าคนเดียวคนอื่น
หัวเราะเยาะคนอื่นมีความสุข
โอเคหัวเราะ
อามีอารมณ์อ่า
มีความสุขใจไหมๆดีใจเราต้องมีเสียใจร้อง
ไห้ใช่ไหมครับอ้าต่อไปให้ต่อไปมีอารมณ์มี
ครับอารมณ์ต่อไปนี่อารมณ์ดีครับ
อารมณ์มีอารมณ์โกรธโกรธเออโปรดใช้กับนี้
ตอนนี้กำลังโกรธนะพี่ Happy วาดให้โกรธ
กว่านี้หน่อยโกรธนั่นแหละมีใช่ไหมโกรธ
R โหลด
หน้าเริ่มโกรธแล้วโกรธหายโกรธกดมากก็จะทำ
ตาโตตาโตได้ไหม Pro เอ้ออ้าเราโกรธตอนไหน
บ้างครับน้องเรียมเคยโกรธไหมครับโกรธไหม
ค่ะ 5 เคยทำไมถึงโปรดครับทำไมถึงโกรธ
เพราะว่าเตรียมไปเซเว่นครับหน้าไปเซเว่น
I  7s เออไปโกรธเซเว่นทำไมครับ
[เพลง]
โอเค
อยู่ไหนน้อนี่
เป็นไปเซเว่น
เซเว่นใช่ไหมคะข่าวขายเขาขายของอยู่
เตรียมก็ไปจอดรถมอเตอร์ไซค์
หน้าหนูทำสรรค์เกมก็จอดรถมอเตอร์ไซค์
มอเตอร์ไซค์แล้วก็ก็เข้าไปในเซเว่นไปซื้อ
ของ
เตรียมออกมาออกมาจากเซเว่นกลับซื้อของ
เสร็จแล้วอ่าเดินออกมาแล้ว
แม่คะเราก็มีรถยนต์
รถยนต์จอดอยู่ศ.
นพยนต์จอด
เตรียมก็วันทำไมมองไม่เห็น
โอเคมีรถยนต์
มีรถยนต์นะคะ
รถยนต์จอดอยู่เรียงก็เอารถมอเตอร์ไซค์
ออกไม่ได้อ๋อ
ใช่ค่ะเตรียมก็เลยรอ
รอแป๊บรอพ่อนานมากๆ
นานมากคะแล้วก็มีมอเตอร์ไซค์หลายๆคันรอรอ
อยู่
ก็เลยขอ
10 นาทีออกไม่ได้
ไม่ได้ได้ใช่มั้ยก็ยี่สิบนาทีข่านไป
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้เหมือนเดิมมา
หลายๆคนทุกๆคนหาออกไม่ได้ออกไม่ได้อ่าน
ทุกคนก็เริ่มโกรธไม่ใช่มั้ยให้เรียงโต๊ะ
โกรธขอ
โปรดอันนี้โกรธควันขึ้นและโกรธให้โกรธรถ
คันนี้ของใครเหอ
ก็คันนี้ของใครมีคนรออยู่
คนคนคน
คนที่มีมอเตอร์ไซค์หรือใน Line อ่ะเด็กใน
ครรภ์จ่ายเขาหลายคนตอบรอรอรอ
รถคันนี้ออกไป
ใช่ค่ะหนารอรอ
นานใช่ไหมรอนานก็โกรธโกรธหน้าไม่มาไม่ออก
ยังไม่ออกรอนานแล้วยังไม่ออกโครตอ่ะออกไป
เดี๋ยวนี้ออกไปใส่ครับหมอก็เลยโกรธโล่
นี่ล่ะค่ะที่
เคยโกรธไหมคะอะเพื่อตีก็โกรธแต่พี่โกรธ
นิดหน่อยไม่ค่อยโกรธเยอะเหอะ
โหลดอะไรคะเดี๋ยวตีโกรธอะไรอาจมีบางครั้ง
เวลาที่เอ่อเวลาที่พี่อาทิตย์ทำทำงานแล้ว
ทำไม่ทันเวลา
ก็เสร็จไม่ทันเพศนี่ก็จะโกรธนิดหน่อยโกรธ
นิดหน่อยน่ะต้องรีบทำให้ทันในบางครั้งก็
ทำไม่ทันก็โกรธโกรธใส่ครับ
จ้า
โปรดโหลดด้วยแล้วก็เครียด
อ๋อ
อันนั้นเครียดโกรธแล้วก็เครียดใช่ไหมครับ
อ่าอยากทำให้ผ่าน
โอเคอ้าวันนี้เราก็ก็เอาอามี 3 อารมณ์ 3
อารมณ์ใช่ไหมครับมาคุยกันมีอารมณ์ที่ 1
นะคะเป็นอารมณ์ดีใจใช่ไหมมีความสุขห่ามี
ความสุขดีใจนะครับแล้วก็อีกล้มนึงอารมภ์
ต่อไปเป็นอารมณ์เศร้าเสียใจเสียใจร้องไห้
นะครับอ่าแล้วก็อารมณ์สุดท้ายอารมณ์สุด
ท้ายเป็นอารมณ์โกรธหา
โกรธนะครับนะคะนักเรียนนักเรียนมีอารมณ์
โกรธบ้างไหมครับนักเรียนอารมณ์แบบไหนครับ
ดีใจเสียใจหรือว่าโกรธหน้ามากที่สุดมี
อารมณ์อันไหนมากที่สุดคีย์ในคอมเม้นบอก
เบียร์ตีบอกน้องเรียนหน่อยนะครับน้า
โอเคแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าครับคราวหน้าเรา
กลับมาเจอกับปาร์ตี้กลับมาเจอกับน้อง
เรียมในช่องคอมเปลี่ยน Store ไทยกันใหม่
นะครับ 5 วันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วหมดเวลาใช่
ครับเดี๋ยวพี่อาร์ตี้กับลาไปก่อนครับ
สวัสดี
ครับสวัสดีครับน้องเรียนสวัสดีครับนัก
เรียนอ่ะบ๊ายบาย
[เพลง]
โปรด
อย่าตีม๊ะโกรธเบ็คส์โรจน์โหลดแอปไม่พูด
อ่ะ
ม.ค